we'll see if they can get it inside Zion  outside man he'll follow his own  shrewder almost through the way Nader  knows clock is down don't stop been  given a nerf locked away by a bad  recovery  the denial see in Billy Donovan then AB  donator is going to have to make Zion  pay at this end that's gonna be tough  six tenths of a second enough time to  catch it and shoot there's both big arc  I'll tell you what I like about che  kilter Alexander's game yes the bench  doing a great job  once again the bench was phenomenal  landscape 59 35 Powell's bench last game  it'll be Chris Paul he fell on his oka  and Zion clears out up against door nice  job he saw  I tried low that Zion Williamson gets  his shoulder but this is a different one  this is the one where he can test it got  out in transition and finish at the rim  [Applause]